genius playing listeners this podcast is
brought to you by betterhelp mental
health is mental wealth if you're
working on your physical health you
should be working on your mental health
as well it is important for you and you
carry this with you for the rest of your
life if you need somebody to talk to if
you are concerned that you're not going
where you need to be this is where
better help can help you sometimes we're
faced with the crossroads in life and we
don't know which path to take whatever
it is therapy can help you map out your
future and trust yourself to find the
way forward if you're thinking about
starting therapy give Better Health a
try it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible is suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com genius today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help help.com genius you'll catch
something new every time yeah I'll show
you guys this clip of this kid the
fight's going down and then he realizes
he's being overpowered this little just
jumps off
God
someone dives into the water there was
one dude that was a warrior he was a
white guy right that was also all right
I've never I've never seen such an ugly
shirt in my life on a person who's even
uglier than the action I've never seen a
potato shine before okay I've seen
potato shine you know why it's an
immersion it's called lotion you wake up
in the morning you spit on your face you
piece of trash
welcome everybody oh we're wrong oh
we're on we're already on
five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode of The
Genius brain podcast we have a very
special guest a special in the sense
that he's an idiot oh yeah Jason Kenny
yeah hey and we also have another very
special guest the the widest Mexican
I've ever met in my life we have Patrick
dot T dot Riley how's it going are you
doing for Terence thank you two for
Terence yes Tortuga you talk too much
[__] all right I didn't say anything yes
you did you said I don't know anything
about wine I know plenty things about oh
my good guy you don't know [__] about
them okay why don't you tell me about
this bottle of wine tell them all right
don't read it though okay I'm not gonna
try it and tell me what you taste okay
but I'm gonna let you know this is a
[__] wine already very nice you can look
at your face you don't buy good wine
look at your face I don't [__] know
that because look at your face wow okay
you know what I mean yeah you sound like
you here we go ahead we all got to sip
in them first I want to hear Jason
that's first
wow
wow wow that is absolute gas station
garbage
first of all
leafy is not good for the podcast what
do you taste then since you're such a
[__] wine connoisseur you idiot what
are the notes
so what you want to do is that when you
sip it you want to put it at the back of
your throat like a penis go ahead
continue
okay
and uh
no you saw it on TV
the first time you literally saw it on
TV you tried it for the first time right
now honestly don't tell everybody that
was a weird technique because usually
they do the yeah your mouth went like
yeah it has to go back there yeah yeah
it's more from the second day and we're
not eating penis so try that again
please okay so you put it in right and
you swirl it around with your with your
tongue but he's doing it right there
that's right
I was not a new technique just like a
penis continue
don't die as long as you got to take a
risk and uh try different I heard that
this was a very cheap good tasty table
wine called Apothic Red okay yeah and I
think it tastes perfectly what do you
taste what do you tastes like notes what
do you what do you taste it tastes like
grape juice that's fermented dude I mean
it doesn't have any it doesn't have real
notes it's not the body's not full the
body doesn't have a full body full body
number one full body number two Oaky
it's not Oaky at all it's just grapes
it's like grapes in the refrigerator you
ever you ever see grapes in the
refrigerator and and there's some that
is fall off the stem and in the bottom
of the tray you see a little brown then
use those grapes for this one yeah I
know what you mean um shout out to
Apothic I'm sorry
you have no idea what you just said
right I said some good stuff no you
didn't know it no you didn't you know
you didn't taste any [__] Oakwood
just now why does it have to taste like
oak oak wood because it makes me feel
alive man
do you you know you had a kid recently
right yeah
boy or girl or are you gonna let them
decide yeah she's uh gender gender
question mark right
she's the person she's the person she's
a human she's a human she's a human what
does it feel like being a dad uh
uh what's it feel like a dad for you man
yeah
because Jason suddenly forgot English
it wasn't like a battle so what now I
think that was a solid rebuttal to be
honest I think that was a good one thank
you yeah you got him don't you think you
don't ever defend me in court for any
type of crime that might commit dude did
they do the crime or not hey what's the
crime so run now
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so I was telling Pat coming up
there and he was telling me that Maya
was the same way uh but I the first
couple months I really didn't care or
like my child wait hold on okay but let
me I Googled it I Googled it before you
judge me okay say your thing first go
ahead say your thing let's go terrible
father continue okay so you know what
I'm talking about the first couple of
months so you know how they say like
when you have the baby you come out you
hold it and you you you feel something
yeah I felt stressed and like like shock
I was like oh my God I'm we she made it
well hold on a second so when the child
came out and yeah I held it so you what
was the face you made okay he was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah why
um because I just felt a immense amount
of pressure to be a good person to be a
good person and I'm not 100 yeah
and then um and I I feel like oh [__] I
have to protect her
um
you know was that you throw like a
football dude
100 yards
what's your wife's name Carrie hey
Carrie it's not too late for divorce
he'll do it you can 100 leave this man
at any given time yeah yeah don't leave
though man
like a little love like two months ago
two months ago because then they have
some personality because the first
couple months you know like it's like
you don't um they cry a lot all the time
and only the mom could feed so then you
feel super guilty
because you're not able to do a lot even
though you do some stuff for the wife
like you know whatever choice is you
still feel really guilty but then now my
daughter has some personality she smiles
when we smile and that's every that's
enough how often do you see your child I
feel like you've never seen your kid I
saw her twice this whole time okay she's
six years old this week the whole time
the whole time the whole time she's been
alive I saw her alive because they're
traveling all the [__] time yeah
that's what I'm saying
that does exactly what I'm saying so
your child is a lawyer yeah your child
doesn't even know you exist
now they do yeah
wow you're Progressive dude thank you
brother for your [__] kids gigantic
she's a little person she's a whole ass
human being dude she has she has
opinions yeah she's in Alex Jones she's
a conspiracy theorist yeah she believes
in Aliens we're on board dude do you I
always wonder this right like because
because both of you have daughters yeah
um how do you how do you reprimand a
daughter because I know a lot of guys
they get really soft around they're baby
girls number one don't say
representative square up I go ahead and
get in the living room square up
we just get down for 30 seconds yeah
that's how we do it do you rough house
with Maya oh yeah I love wrestling she
likes to wrestle too but yeah I love
wrestling with her I try to get her to
punch my hand I want her to know how to
fight but she's not that into it like I
bought her a little uh a little speed
bag like a little like pole with a
little punching bag and at first she was
hitting it and I was like yeah like like
[__] yeah like praise and then that
lasted maybe 30 minutes and now she just
hugs it and says it's her best friend oh
[Music]
she needs to know how to defend herself
I think you need a force that I'm gonna
force my my daughter for sure I took my
daughter to Muay Thai and she like was
in the class she was doing the warm-ups
and she like couldn't kick over this
thing and just got super pissed off and
just sat behind a bag and was like oh I
hate this
I'm like [__] [__] like there she is
frustrated for you she gets frustrated
but I want her to know how to fight
because like it's important
maybe I might put her in Jitsu she might
like that a little more I feel like kids
like Jiu Jitsu a lot because it's it's
just what they do anyways
that's true she is into that like we'll
wrestle and [__] and she like I'll try
to teach her how to do like a real naked
choke yeah but anytime I try to push
something too much she's like in instant
like I'm out like she just doesn't like
if I'm pushing something so I have to
kind of let her
[Music]
like she's a girl she likes dance she
loves ballet hip-hop dancing she likes
to color and [__] that's not the animals
it's nice
[Laughter]
she's dope but like I just want to know
how to fight I said like I don't know
she has to be a pro fighter I just want
her to be able to defend herself because
I know right now like you want her to be
interested in something so that she
could be passionate but then would there
be a point where you force her a little
bit just so that in the future she
doesn't do them in there's I think
because I don't want my daughter to give
the artwork I don't even know what the
[__] you're gonna teach her kid you
can't even read yourself continue
Daddy can you read a bedtime story can
you read me a bedtime story daddy sleepy
too
yeah but it's better practice for them
you do it because I'm testing you I know
I know yeah I know obviously I know yeah
I know I know how to read I know how
read you know how to read you know
really I read now you know read how now
you read now how now uh yeah I mean
there might be a point where like I just
mandatory at least know the basics yeah
like I don't know the basics probably
like she's about to turn six I'd
probably say like in a year or two she's
still really little you know like six is
still pretty young but like seven I
think eight it'll be good I'm gonna try
Jujitsu I'm just gonna take her and just
see that I feel like a lot of kids
gravitate towards like wrestling a jiu
jitsu yeah because they're just [__]
around anyways yeah so like I've
definitely seen like the kid Jiu Jitsu
classes all the kids are having the
[__] time of their life yeah and it's
mainly based on like what the instructor
instructor does that kind of allows them
to have like a learning environment but
I've definitely seen like kisses
gravitate towards that first before they
start trying to punch and strike [__]
yeah I feel like the little boys I don't
know what it is like genetically boys
just like to break things yeah so once
you tell them like hey at the end of the
test you get to break a board they're
like okay yeah let's [__] do this
yeah yeah just breaking [__] when I was
a kid
when I became a yellow belt in Taekwondo
I will forever remember this yellow bell
is the second belt man I was a [__]
kid you idiot oh so anyways
I was five and when I became a yellow
belt when you become a yellow belt is
when you are allowed to spar so I was
like five or six years old and I
remember I was so [__] hyped because
I get to Sock somebody and not get in
trouble and so they were like to me like
which is like get ready and then see
Jack would just means start I just
[__] socked this kid right in his
mouth damn because we're only supposed
to use kicks and I just flip right in
the face and the kid just falls to the
floor
I was like this that's weird I thought I
won like no no no we're only doing kicks
right now but I was like why am I in
trouble he's [__] weak as [__] yeah I
won and so instead of punching him in
the face on the next one he did
I stood up 25 [__] Hammer fist at the
top of his head
I wasn't allowed to spar for like a week
dude I [__] loved sparring it was
like oh [__] it was a thing that got be
super excited to go to Cloud oh yeah it
was so fun when you're a kid especially
like a boy like you love just breaking
things the best the doing like learning
how to do the spinning back heel kicks
the back straight kicks it's fantastic
yeah I took Kempo when I was a kid and
they used to make a spar of the class
but sometimes they would do like two on
one or three on one and that was my
favorite I liked being the one guy and
it was like 2001 yeah like four kids we
were like six or seven we were young but
still there's like three other like
five-year-olds and you had to just
[__] I would just be socking dudes it
was so it was so fun dude it was the
best just punching the [__] out of the
kid my studio
yeah
[__] Dwight Street in the office
[__] stalking kids in the face like
our our studio went out of business
because like our guy was so serious
about like taekwondo so there was this
was during the time when a lot of like
mcdojos were popping up and so they
figured out a way to make it a business
so it wasn't about learning the martial
art it was about taking money for belts
so if you want to become a yellow belt
well it's 200 okay well you want to be a
green belt was another 200 so they were
just making money that way well our guy
was super old-fashioned Korean you
didn't get a belt unless you deserved
that [__] but business-wise it wasn't
really [__] good
so for us we had to earn our way up
these [__] ranks dude if I would have
the dojo everybody would be a black man
five thousand dollars blackout now
free classes they start teaching oh they
[__] improved a 16th degree black
belt they paid twenty thousand dollars
for this just in one class promoter 17
times our people were really [__]
good though like in the class just
because like our yellow belts were like
demolishing everybody else and our green
belts were demolishing everybody above
them because when you first started
sparring you would Spar people with your
same belt but after that he would have
all the young kids Spar people
so we were never given a break so like
we had one guy that was like an Olympic
gold medalist coming flying from Korea
and he just wailed on us dude damn like
[__] ridiculous I remember this guy
sidekicked me so hard I [__] flew
into the wall like a Dragon Ball Z
character and then he was just like
second round just keep going and he
would just wail on us wow but everybody
in our team was really good like every
time we went to a tournament we all got
medals and we all came back it was
[__] amazing that's awesome you
wouldn't have gotten a bill I will get a
belt for sure absolutely I will pay him
220 yeah
yeah give it to me now now dude did you
guys see it's like all over the internet
the [__] that happened in Alabama no
yeah I did you didn't see it yes it was
epic as [__] it's going to be a national
holiday for sure I don't know what the
backstory is dude let me tell you this
[__] box
so when you first see this video right
it's literally a all-out [__] black
versus white brawl so it's at like the
seaport like this Ferry
so when you first see this video it
looks like a security guard that's
getting jumped by a bunch of hillbilly
white people right and it looks just
like a racial beat down and so people
you know at first on the internet before
they jump to any conclusions they want a
backstory which I agree with right
they're like well what's the backstory
the back story is ten times worse than
what you initially thought there was a
ferry that has a bunch like a cruise not
a cruise ship but it's like a ferry that
goes around the port or whatever but not
right
and uh they have to dock here but
there's these people like a group of
let's say six or seven white people
hillbilly ass folks that were docked
they docked their boat in the area
that's meant for the ferry right and
they know this and these guys are
telling them like hey move this is from
a witness accounts that are saying what
happened and they're like hey you need
to move you need to move it they're not
getting off their spot and they're just
doing obscene gestures whether that's
like the
you see that they were saying like
racial [__] too or whatever whatnot so
one of the co-captains there's a smaller
boat that takes him takes them over
there and then I guess he moves their
boat and he tells them like hey you have
to move like you legally can't be here
and so that in turn turns out into a
fight where they just start [__]
wailing on this guy or they decided to
fight together and look my favorite part
of the video If you haven't seen is like
they're arguing and then off jump the
black guy goes he goes like this
[Music]
there was no words because I couldn't
hear what they were saying yeah but it
sounded from what I saw like he did this
and he goes not today [__] like
this is like the the [__] the black
signal
he turned it around and then he's gonna
pop that [__] off he tossed it like a
showman dude like he's like put it all
like that
and just started throwing down hard so
this dude and the other dude just start
[__] wailing on each other right then
all of a sudden you see this hillbilly
[__] come out of nowhere these others
like two other white guys and they start
jumping this guy yeah so all the black
folk in the area see what's going down
because it's [__] up and then now it's
like the Optics are not good it's you're
in Alabama and there's like six white
dudes beating the [__] out of one boy
not good exactly the other favorite part
is that so they're on they're on the
dock getting down they're throwing down
right they're kind of jumping this the
black dude who's looks like a security
guard and then there's like a waterway
in between and there's a dock on the
other side one of the black dudes swims
across dude like like he's like they're
in the middle of a fight and this guy's
just swimming like I'm gonna [__]
somebody up when I get there he's
swimming gets up on the dock takes the
shoes off he like kind of rustles
himself off as the fight's going on the
whole fight's going on he immediately
just suplexes the [__] out of somebody
like comes over there just two types of
[__] out of somebody amazing and let me
tell you something you know what's crazy
about that listen I'm not I'm not saying
any racial [__] right this is what the
internet says for a black person to go
into water yeah and swim on their own
they're like this [__] deserves
an award yeah yeah give him an Olympic
medal and give him the key to the
[__] City yeah who said they can't
swim but I know who said the black
person this [__] Swift let's
swim those dirty ass Waters climb up on
the dock then suplex somebody fully
clothed too in jeans yeah jeans get
heavy in the water yeah that was a bad
move on his part I don't know why you
did that but it took him a minute to get
over there though it took like a solid
five minutes
no it has to be so quick because the
fight is going on yeah I mean the fight
was going on for about three minutes
still going yeah it was going oh my God
it was a long fight and you so if you
look up a picture of this kid right it
all makes sense I so my buddy sent me a
photo of him and I'm like I get it now
he's an anime fan this kid is like one
of those anime weebs he has like a
full-on anime t-shirt to do that to him
do that swim he has he has an anime
necklace and I'm like this was his anime
moment oh I just love the idea like I've
never been swimming and been like I'm
gonna [__] somebody else
just turned around
my lovely genius brain listeners are you
stressed are you tired do you just need
somebody to talk to you so you can get
the Wiggles out well that's where better
help comes genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends my friends I have been
talking about mental health and how
important it is in your life sometimes
we're faced with a crossroad in life and
we don't know which path to take maybe
you're thinking about a career change or
feeling like your relationship needs
some TLC whatever it is therapy can help
you map out your future and trust
yourself to find the way forward my
friends better help has been helping me
for quite a while and I freaking love it
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with the licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com
off your first month that's better help
atlp.com genius
there's this photo that had me in tears
laughing so there's there's one white
dude that got his ass beat and he was
wearing Crocs well by the end of the
fight when he got arrested somehow he
tore the Crocs to the point where it
became shin guards it went through his
feet oh my God and the guy that was the
ultimate winner dude is this dude that
had a foldable chair and he was smashing
people with it I didn't see that
actually bro that's the funniest part of
the video that video goes on for like
five minutes
I did saw a clip wait so the fight
starts on like that side of the dock and
then somehow ends up on this side where
the dudes initially swam from somehow
the fight comes over there and like the
brawl continues on the other side that's
how long this fight is it like it
travels locations
with funny ass they call it the Alabama
sweet tea party
dude one of the best memes was so like
the fight ends up on the other side a
couple of the hillbilly dudes are on
their boat I don't I'm assuming they're
from the initial group like like four or
five black dudes come up start [__]
them up on the boat like start cracking
them on the boat the white lady is
getting jumped and then the white lady
there's like a white lady that's getting
[__] up by these black chicks and then
but one of the best memes I saw was like
it's the white dudes on on the other
side of the dock too and then they have
the Avengers you know like the the the
Doctor Strange
people it's playing The Avengers theme
song the the two circles yeah and
they're like show up I don't know
you don't know what I'm talking about I
do is it too lyrical thing the two
circle thing when they come back
it was it was there's this guy that had
a foldable chair and he kept I didn't
imagine people it's so that's like the
biggest meme that's going around like
there's like people going in Costco
grabbing chairs with people freaking the
[__] out there's like people making
earrings out of chairs so you see this
dude just [__] smacking people in the
head with like the WWE steel chairs yeah
and then kind of goes off Street and
he's not there anymore and there's this
white lady trying to get back up he
comes back in the screen frame hey wow
it was [__] how long was the fight
the fight went on for [__] like
legitimately 15 20 minutes ever dude it
was insane that was one thing like if
you watch this video 40 times you'll
catch some something new every time yeah
I'll show you guys this clip of this kid
the fight's going down and then he
realizes he's being overpowered this
fool just jumps off
what get into the water the water just
types
there was one dude that was a warrior he
was a white guy right that was also
working on the majority of the fairy
workers seem to be uh like black
American
those white guy he tried to step in one
of the hillbilly guys looked at him and
I [__] you [__] not he goes for a
dick punch he sucks a white boy in the
dick wow he screws around and he I
thought he was gonna sock him in the
face and he angles and wow dick punches
him wow the weirdest [__] fight in
history this is gonna be in history
books oh yeah it is that significant you
talking about Civil War [__] that dude
we're talking about the Alabama sweet
tea party
is the best thing I see I spent hours
watching this [__] I couldn't stop
laughing yeah it's unbelievable and it's
juicy people often the side just make a
side commentary and it's I'm crying
laughing yeah the comment section is the
best
dude everybody has something people were
making memes immediately dude this whole
[__] the whole back turn and then
throwing the hat in the air so good
everybody was meeting you so good they
said it's like the signal for one of you
to be helpful with black folks
it was amazing I can't believe you
haven't seen that [__] I I saw the memes
and stuff but I didn't see the actual
video I think I saw like a like a gif of
like the chair guy but I didn't see the
whole [__] that was [__] everybody
I'll tell you this though man like you
want to see something that kind of gets
a community to come together that was
actually pretty amazing to see because
like you said like the Optics were
terrible they're bad options Alabama for
one sweet black American and by the way
he was just doing his [__] job yeah
yeah like these guys were [__] they
refused to move their [__] boat in a
place that they're not supposed to be
and the the fairy apparently was parked
out in the water for 45 minutes because
they wouldn't move their boat oh [__] so
that's why they had to get a smaller
boat for him to come up on dock and then
move their boat because they wouldn't
[__] move and they're not supposed to
be there and they were just doing a
bunch of like racial [__] and it's just
amazing that there was multiple
locations for this fight I love that I
love that the guy swam to beat
somebody's ass that's gonna be a first
20 minutes but in his head he's like
this is like you said the anime anime
movement dude you're speaking Japanese
and everything yeah yeah
don't worry
you should see his [__] police
interviews all the Japanese yeah
what the [__]
there was a there was like a series of
white people
either come here you speak Japanese
that kid was [__] amazing that's
amazing dude I want to interview him on
the podcast even it's the five minute
interview I don't get [__] I'm like
what the [__] were you thinking
phenomenal yeah but once once that boat
like that fairy parked everybody started
coming out and it was just Mayhem dude
everybody was just lighting people to
[__] up
a mix do you think you would have done
that like let's say you saw everything
going down I'm gonna tell you something
I'm not I'm not gonna swim over which is
the thing I'll do you first respect okay
I've never heard anybody say that for
pouring wine but continue he just took
it out of my hands
I'm gonna do your wine then I'll do you
I'm gonna do you real nice
swim not swim but let's say depend on
who it is though so wait wait there's
the anime guy know that the the other
friend so the anime dude was actually
one of the employees on the ferry yeah
so he saw everything go down okay mostly
employees yeah oh then they're
co-workers so those employees and then
also just like bystanders too they just
weren't having it yeah these fools were
[__] doing a racial beating I will go
but depending on how far the river is
because I don't want to go there because
I have bad uh cardio I don't want to
swim over and get jumped you are a piece
of [__] dude no but I don't want to swim
over and get jumped like
let me explain this to you I don't want
to swim over
thank you well let's say you're one of
the people that are watching would you
have like yeah I don't believe it but
continue let's see why did you ask me a
question because I want to show people
how [__] trashy you are I know Pat
with Pat would you start swing on
everybody children women
actually I would isolate them actually
you will move the adults out the way
sir get out of the way
yeah that would be my move for sure 100
take advantage there's like a bunch of
dudes that weren't the workers they were
just like uh guys that saw [__] go down
they saw the Injustice happen yeah and
I've never seen when you see like a
bunch of like black dudes start skipping
that means they gonna [__] you up these
[__] like I've never seen like
five black dudes like skedaddle like
they were just like yeah they were
skipping down
yup I'm like you don't know
you gonna get [__] up yeah yeah that's
it's like when a black person comes up
to you like this would happen all the
time they're like and they skip no they
would just walk up to you right and be
like what's up you can get sucked up
he's gonna stop I got stuck many times
when I was a kid yeah all the time
they're like what's up I'm like oh [__]
and then boom just start unloading on
you I'm gonna tell you something I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell you you
guys something man well when I was in uh
junior year in uh in high school my
friend young goal he got that's not a
real name
that's my really good friend yeah so he
got in a fight with this uh with this
guy
and it was supposed to be one-on-one but
then we're at the back of a YMCA and uh
um that guy invited his Armenian friends
and there was like no exaggeration six
more of them and they were like 17 18 19
and um the he was winning my friend was
winning and he got the other guy took
his grabbed my friend's hair and then
started uppercutting him and then I
jumped in and I got jumped dude
[Music]
but then they didn't jump in
and were they Taiwanese
one of them was one of them Taiwan I was
really disappointed
I'll tell you right now if all those
[__] were Korean they would all
jumped in
yeah that's what that's what I'm saying
that's why and I uh never seen somebody
had their hair cracked and then uppercut
my friend was on top of somebody well on
top of the guy and then the other guy
just grabbed his hair Sucker Punch Yeah
Yeah eight times with the thing and I
jumped in and then I started beating
your friend's ass too
[Laughter]
hello
bro
I've never been either what is this who
are you
more punches please please yes I just
want to let you know that I was doing
yeah yeah which really sucks ass dude
dude at one point um they had they had a
baseball bat I think I got hit by a
baseball is the tin one is that why you
talk the way you do that exactly
before before the baseball he was hi I'm
Jason Jenny
the baseball hit hello everybody what's
going on
[Laughter]
what was the fight about it was like
some AOL [__] like dude AOL [__] like
when you guys were doing
yeah like talking [__] online I was in
high school what was your um screen name
it was um Jigglypuff what huh
it wasn't really jiggly but what was it
really no buff Jigglypuff no no yes it
was
I think it's a small X and then big X
and then buff Jigglypuff and then big X
and small X you know how they did that
yeah yeah
don't call yourself a day dude did you
do yeah
what I didn't do that dog mine was time
to bomb your mom what's my screen name
yeah that was made yeah that's crazy
yeah that is so on brand
of you I'm [__] age 13. do you guys
remember this thing on uh aim where you
could text this like AI robot yeah and
they will respond back to everything
yeah so there was this Korean fog that
we knew
he doesn't know how anything Works in
this country so he has he has aim and I
forgot what that what that bot was
called [__] what was it called but if
you if you message it it just responds
back with whatever [__] so you could be
like go [__] yourself and they'll be
like why what are you gonna do yeah
right but we told this fool that this
guy was an Affiliated gang member and
like dude what if we just curse at him
right and he was like no don't do it
like I'm scared he's a great guy right
no you can do it if you do that I'm
gonna die and so I would we would grab
it like just write some crazy [__] like
let's meet up we'll [__] kill you
right now he goes why you do that don't
do that he started crying I started
crying because he thought he was gonna
die and so we kept typing back this
[__] I'm crying laughing yeah
yeah because he doesn't know that this
isn't a real [__] person yeah sure
and so you know they start because the
the robot would respond back sarcastic
sarcastically like it's irritating it's
like oh yeah how are you gonna do it
then question mark right and then we're
typing back we're gonna do with a
[__] knife because yeah what kind of
knife and he was
if you keep the I'm not going to live
he started crying and we actually forgot
to tell him it wasn't a real person oh
no yeah because we were laughing so
[__] hard since that wasn't paranoid
for like a week and then out of nowhere
like we remember because I hadn't seen
him in a [__] week it's like bro
where have you been he's like dude you
guys you guys are [__] around too much
you know I'm gonna die so he wouldn't
leave his house oh wow bro that's not a
real person we [__] that's probably
one of the worst things I've ever done
that's [__] hilarious I love that I'm
a good friend yeah that's good that's
hilarious I love them I actually missed
them a lot his this guy used to call um
he couldn't pronounce LeBron James you
would pronounce him Lebanon James
Lebanese James hey it's Lebanese jams so
this little shoot he will play ball
right you know everybody will say like
Kobe or some [__] this [__]
would be like Lebanon
kind of like this one says Michaela dude
yeah
Michaela is our lovely producer today
can you please say her name sorry
Michaela
now you learned it
[Laughter]
I still can't believe you just need an
Alabama brawl dude I'm gonna go Google
it after it's one of the best that and
then also Andrew Schultz [__]
roasting did you see that [__] the milk
boys yeah that was good too so first of
all I don't even know who the milk boys
are I only have heard of them because of
the UFC so Dana White has like a
relationship with these milk boy guys
because his kid loves the milk boys but
I actually don't know what the milk boys
do okay for those of you who don't know
um no boys is what
for those of you who don't know I know
[Music]
what's up dog every time you talk it
sounds like you're having a seizure and
it stresses me out wait let me tell you
something I don't have a seizure
do you know who the nut boys are yeah
but you you know I want you to go ahead
okay the no boys are
um a type of indigenous tribe okay
am I wrong no I don't think that's what
I'm saying yeah yeah they're they
originated from New Zealand and now
because they immigrated to the United
States the what the United States United
States and also Eastern Europe okay am I
far off Oh no you're pretty close that's
what I'm saying okay so what's your
version okay so good so anyways for
people who aren't [__] impaired
the note was I still don't know who they
are exactly so I cannot uh confirm or
deny what he said okay but they do
Social Media stuff and influencing stuff
there's a guy named um I think Steve's
gonna do it or something like that
what's his name there's a stizzy or
steezy yeah there's a guy named Steve
and there's another dude and there's
another guy named steiny that's the one
yeah so they have this podcast where and
I think they also have a drink brand
they're pretty well off they're actually
[__] wealthy as [__] but I don't know
from what I don't know exactly what they
[__] do but they have a podcast and
they got Andrew Schultz on it right so
everybody who doesn't know who Andrew
Schultz says Andrew Schultz is a very
very prolific famous stand-up comic
right he's like one of the newer younger
people of our age that is slowly coming
into the likes of greatness right uh
blew up during the pandemic because he
started doing these uh one-off
um shows where he would make you rotate
your phone and he would just do these
rapid fire jokes about all this content
that was happening during pandemic with
him and a bunch of his writer friends
got picked up on Netflix and really
sparked him off and then all of a sudden
you know obviously you know you do it a
lot too you do it well when you put your
stand-up clips and his stand-up Clips
started [__] blowing up so Andrew
Schulz this is just the background for
people who don't know who he is
he gets contacted to do the podcast with
the milk boys and is probably one of the
most awkward [__] interviews I've
ever seen in my life oh I saw a clip
where he was like going yeah yeah what
bothers you the most right now nothing
nothing bothers you you look at your
phone
and everybody's feeling disinterested
were you looking at notes or or texting
no no it's yeah what do you mean me
taking time out of my day to do this and
then feeling dude I've never forcing you
guys to do the podcast I've never been
more excited to do a podcast say again
I've never been more excited I'm sorry I
don't apologize no apologize you asked
me what annoyed me and I gave you an
honest answer wait are you being serious
about that yeah that annoyed me really
yes so is that surprising to you well if
I'm looking at my notes I have some
things personally that I wrote that I
wanted to ask you not okay okay so I
can't look at that and then ask you that
I mean you can I guess what if someone
in the audience is on their phone when
you're doing it and they don't get the
same treatment you got would you call
them out yes have you done that before
yes and how's that reaction
good they get as offensive as I do I
don't think you're offensive I think
you're offended offended yeah yeah
and so steiny
I don't know who he is and I don't know
what he does exactly but in this case
like Andrew schill starts going in on
him and originally the podcast wasn't
supposed to release because Andrew
didn't want to come out because it was
such a bad podcast but you know like
when you're at his level
you know he's taking the time to come
out and do this because of somebody that
they're connected to and respect this
podcast to be they would do a little
research or actually have something to
talk about
and so Andrew Schultz is actually
visibly getting [__] irritated
because they're asking him nonsense
questions they're awkward Dead Space
there's no real conversation happening
like for example they would ask him
stuff like so you know you as a stand-up
have you ever like you know gone to the
crowd and talked to them he's like yeah
oh my God I should hurt my heart just
now yeah it's so cringe it like like
listening to the I'm like what are you
talking about right now and that was his
face like how we feel is with his face
would show he's like yeah I'm a stand-up
what the [__] are you talking about so
literally did zero research about who he
is and mind you like as somebody in his
level
he has to take time out of his day to do
this [__] right he's going negative
doing the thing exactly I mean it's not
like he doesn't have two very very
popular [__] podcast shows himself
right right he has the one with
Charlemagne the God he has the one with
uh him and his boys yeah flagrant right
so I don't understand what the [__] the
whole point was them to get him on here
to ask him absolutely nothing and Andrew
Schultz just starts going he laser
focused on steiny he's like you know
what he's just like so what do you do
you know yeah yeah exactly simple
questions he's like well I don't
understand why you're going still in on
him he goes like you're just inauthentic
yeah it's like you're being fake
being really phony and then he started
texting that's what irritated him too oh
yeah he's like I'm annoyed that you're
talking why would you do that though
yeah why would you do that and so Andrew
shits on him for a while yeah and that
fool gets up walks back and then asks
him like Hey man like what's going you
could see him like he's here he's like
irritated like why are you coming after
me and the Schultz is like I think
you're just being fake and you're always
super mean
yeah like you're a [__] weirdo fake
ass and then he was like oh dude
well that's the thing too like you know
when I was watching that [__] I wonder
for a lot of people who develop their
online Persona and a lot of these online
Persona kids who who get Fame in a way
where they don't have to earn it right
they don't know what to do with it and
so a lot of people who either want to be
with him or [__] him or whatever right
their fans of his already so he doesn't
have to put in any effort into him as an
individual as a person
to even develop anything but guess what
when you're over here and you're in a
space with the comic who's very
quick-witted and he could smell that
[__] on you yeah he's gonna call you out
and it just goes to show that somebody
like him I'm not sure about the other
two they seem perfectly fine and normal
yeah like their their conversation
skills seems great but this guy
specifically he doesn't know what the
[__] he's doing at all he can't hold a
conversation he could barely make eye
contact and he's wondering why Andrew
Schultz is like well why are you [__]
going in on me it's like no this is real
life [__] yeah like you act like
this little douchebag [__] somebody's
gonna rip the [__] into you what are you
talking about he was being a douchebag
because I didn't know I watched I had no
contacts I just saw the clip so I'll say
this right let's say like
I mean for you now right like you're
you're growing you're getting bigger
right and um let's say somebody you know
you you have a kid now you're busy or
whatever what none is this so come on to
this podcast and during the podcast I
just go no but that's really rude that's
what I would nobody should ever do that
but I just I was wondering about his
personality like how I don't know about
it it's just kind of like you know like
the the YouTubey type like yeah it's
just like you just like you know what's
weird influencer type [__] like
yeah you know what I mean it's like just
like shallow vapid conversations like
all [__] like oh okay just not just
into you know what I mean yeah that's
the opposite of Andrew Schultz for sure
I I guess I was just trying to be the
Devil's Advocate because sometimes I
will see like a clip on whatever the
thing is like on the tick tocks or
whatever and it was it's like really
awkward I think her name was I think
Gabby or something like She interviewed
uh Drake and then
um Mark Cuban and she like blew up but
it's like her style it was very dry
really dry yeah but you can tell it's
quite a joke yeah she's playing a joke
yeah both of them are doing the same
joke with each other so they're doing
yes and back and forth yeah yeah so this
one was more like he's like on his phone
and then there's just like it's like am
I boring you like what's going on here
that's bad oh I'm just checking my notes
he goes you're not checking your [__]
notes though like yeah it's pretty
[__] obvious yeah and then the most
awkward moment of the podcast he you
know he's obviously getting frustrated
because Andrew's going in on him and
then he assumes that Andrew Schultz is
Jewish because steiny oh yeah yeah and
he goes like dude I [__] you know
took out he started speaking Hebrew to
him and he's like not Jewish he's like
he thinks I'm Jewish oh my God
and it just gets more and more Awkward
yeah I mean look to be fair he he kind
of either looks like he's like [__]
evil Luigi or he could be Jewish you
know so I can see why he thought he was
Jewish yeah yeah but like that was so
but that even goes to show like you
really know absolutely nothing about me
and you did this podcast for no [__]
reason because you know I'm a big name
but you didn't give a [__] enough to
even care you're right [__]
disrespectful yeah you know what I'm
saying and then he said one thing on his
podcast when he was talking about
he basically said I forgot what the
exact quote was but he says like he's
one of the most untalented people that
he's ever met that actually came
successful all right which is a pretty
fair assessment for what I've seen from
that sure of course let me ask you now
because you do the Pod right
um but do you feel at times
um that you have to because I feel like
a lot of the times if sometimes I'm
awkward
all the time but continue okay but don't
say all the time
no because but sometimes do you feel
like it's hard because I feel like it
comes pretty easy for the both of yous
so I know sometimes you ask questions
and sometimes you add information and
sometimes you make a fun thing but is it
hard for you guys to like do keep a keep
it like a pod at you know what I mean
like on a train
like just to keep it moving or do you
have to think about it or is it just
like second nature because like I could
fill in gaps pretty you're really good
at that you're really good at like
shifting and like you're very good at
like keeping the momentum going but it's
easy for you for me I wouldn't say it's
necessarily easy or it's more natural
it's definitely natural right I I will
say this like when I was younger and
I've talked about this multiple times
like I've I had social anxiety like a
[__] yeah so I couldn't talk to
people yeah but on the videos though you
you do the things so let me tell you so
this was a [__] practice skill like I
had to work at this [__] [__] hard
that's not true because let me tell you
you keep saying that it's not true
because in the videos even like in the
in the old days you do it and it's like
quick but I'm talking about even further
back than that
you're wrong about yourself
don't you dare [__] insult me in my
native language that's not my name's
language you're wrong about yourself
so like when I live in his past I know
he's talking about this my past years
that's a [__] lie no like I had like
social anxiety my dad used to beat my
ass because I couldn't talk to people
that was hilarious did it work yeah you
know what I'm saying why don't you say a
hello huh like Dad I can't I get nervous
you know wasn't nervous and when I punch
you in your mouth beating your [__]
ass he would get mad and what I found as
an adult is like
you see how I solve my problems it's not
learned yeah yeah I thought I was adult
my dad has social anxiety yeah he's a
[__] pastor wow trippy as [__] and I
started noticing this when I got older
when he can't order food himself he when
he's not confident that he can't speak
English he won't talk to people he's not
going outside so it's weird that's later
though
no this is him his whole life no he
could talk to us how the [__] is this
I'm gonna tell you you're wrong
there's no more garbage wine dude
[Music]
the red blend it's in the back you want
me to grab it it's a red blood sugar
okay
you [__] jackass talking about the
milk boys the tribe and his dad
okay because when your father and your
mother or mine okay because Korean and
when they came and they have to raise
you your father has to order food and he
did it you just didn't see it like I
never ordered food never order food we
rarely rarely ever went out to eat the
only places that we ever went out to eat
were a couple of spots there was a place
called a Hawaii Vietnamese restaurant
and another place called pukong which
was a Korean Chinese spot so my dad
specifically never went out to eat and I
only found this I only started cooking
this all together recently whenever time
I would go back to Sacramento my mom's
like I want to go out to eat it's
because you're dead and I'm like oh [__]
that's not we never went out crazy
nobody else was saving money though that
too we're also poor like even something
small so check this [__] out when my
mom's mom died when I was a kid
um I only met her once uh from what I
remember when I went back to Korea when
I was eight so my mom had to go back to
Korea for about a week and my dad was in
charge of feeding us and cookie first
right
the whole time because my dad doesn't
want to go out order food or do anything
he made us the same [__] dish
breakfast lunch and dinner for eight
days it was peas and carrots the Frozen
bag and he would put it in rice mush it
up and then he would take a thin thin
layer of eggs and put on top and just
slide it and catch up I ate that for
[__] three meals a day for eight days
[__] hell yeah when my mom came back I
cried because I I was like
and then my boss how was it dude fed is
this all day and I remember this
specifically my mom looks at him in
Korea she goes you couldn't [__]
order pizza like what are you out of
your [__] mind he's like it's fine
it's food and she goes what's wrong with
you they started yelling at each other
the first day that she's back so pissed
at him but now I get it because he was
he has social anxiety so he can't really
do any of that [__] and I I think he saw
things in me that he hated in himself
because he wanted to change that yeah
you like better and it didn't [__]
work I had to do it myself so I started
doing things super out of my comfort
which was stand up okay
what's up what pushed you to do it I
just hated it about myself I [__]
hated that when I talked to people I
couldn't look them in the eye I know but
a lot of people hate that about
themselves but they don't have the thing
to just because I'm not a [__] all
right I ain't no [__] [__] also if
you don't make eye contact with people
girls just don't like you yeah they
don't know who they're who you're
talking you want to go on a date
hey man I like those titties
[Music]
but I didn't like the social like
anxiety which I still have it now but
I've learned to like develop certain
social cues and it took a lot of [__]
flopping right it's like damn she didn't
like it when I said this I'm coming on
too strong I'm trying to be too funny
and I had to cycle through this for like
seven or eight years till I finally
caught a rhythm and now that I'm a
[__] adult I know what that rhythm is
so when I see people do that I almost
said like y'all could change it you just
have to work on it you know because I I
didn't my dad wasn't a smooth talker my
dad was only got married to my mom
because my mom hunted him down like a
[__] Amazonian Savage no uh like when
I see him like the way my mom would
describe my my dad she goes don't ever
don't ever take [__] dating advice
from your dad he doesn't know anything
I'm his first girlfriend and I had to
chase him he didn't have to do anything
I'm like now it makes sense and let me
wrap back to this other story where my
remember I told you this where my dad
was trying to get my brother to date
this girl and he's trying to give him
advice about how to date and now it
clicked I was like oh [__] my dad's a
nerd like he doesn't know how to talk to
women because he never had to so when my
brother was he was trying to get him to
date this Korean girl that lived next
door
so we kind of had Thanksgiving together
because we don't have a lot of family
around
she comes today so we're gonna have
Thanksgiving together and so my dad
wakes my brother up at like five or six
a.m in the morning he's like she's
coming over and I'm like my brother
wakes up he goes it's [__] she's coming
over at like 4 P.M you have to get ready
it's like 5 a.m so my brother's pissed
and I just hear my brother young I come
outside I'm looking at my dad I was like
what's going on he goes she's going to
come over he has to get ready I'm like
it's
here yeah yeah and so my dad it's 8 AM
comes back into his room he goes hey so
she likes drinks so you should go like
make her a Martinique
or so my dad's like do you want me to
get like a martini shaker so you can
make her a drink and I'm like looking at
my dad what the [__] do you think he's
gonna do she's gonna walk in the door
hello
she's taking us this is what my dad
thinks dating is yeah he's never dated
before for good intention though good
intention yeah yeah
[Music]
that's definitely what you did for your
wife hello hello I didn't make that face
though but I did do this
yeah my dad was trying to tell my
brother to make her [__] mixed drinks
like a barista at [__] Thanksgiving
while the rest of us just watch to watch
him making Martini he gets a [__]
orange peel and just [__] lights on
fire
so like I'm learning more about my
parents every [__] day it's like this
is a new one this is a new one this one
was just uh last year I figured this out
about my dad I was like he has zero
experience with women so he doesn't
actually know what it is so he was
trying to get my brother to text her
like five times a day he was like I
texted her and you know it's like we're
not having good conversation he goes
well you need to text her more girls
like that I'm like no that's stalking
sir absolutely can I ask you a question
you have the mic right
so if if a guy texted you multiple how
many times do you think too much is for
a guy to text you to get your attention
like in a row in a row oh more than two
there you go yeah I would have answered
you after the second time 100 yeah yeah
yeah so Michaela knows what's up that's
a normal girl right right so if a girl
though Michaela was saying was that if
okay if I didn't respond back after the
second one I'm either clearly not
interested or I'm doing something else
I'm busy I'm busy I'm busy so my dad's
thing is like listen
two times and not enough like a 17. you
know do like a 17 times where are you
yeah where are why are you not
responding to me you're 17. like about a
17 so divided by times 18. you know so
he would just keep my brother was
getting hit so I had to come in and tell
my dad to leave him alone it's like
that's not how it works he goes why
what's the problem he said you texted
him one time if she don't read
you know how to get a real [__]
my father dude
I was a virgin until I was 18. it's
apparently for kids now is uh early
yeah there's no way that people are
[__] in their 14. I was 14. yo yeah
I mean I look back on it now I'm like
damn that was the youngest [__] who did
you lose your virginity to my first
girlfriend and where her name was
crystal
what the [__] dude Crystal
Broome your mother whatever name
[Music]
mother
no we've been on MySpace bro her name
was crystal what how did you mean on
MySpace she lived in the area she lived
in so I was in South Pasadena she was in
Commerce which is like East l.a-ish kind
of here so she was kind of like you know
a little [__]
and uh we met I just started messaging
her on [__] Myspace we had a mutual
friend I just started talking to her I
was like hey what's up I don't remember
what I was saying but I was just
flailing like trying anything and for
some reason she was down we hung out and
like it didn't matter what she was horny
she was horny yeah she was horny so we
started we started dating and you know
and we had sex what you what what how
old was she it's the same age we're both
I think yeah we're both 14. how many
kids does she have now
now she she didn't have any kids at the
time but we were definitely she would
take the bus dude and we like first time
we had sex was in the back my buddy had
a back house and like no one was there
his parents weren't home and I was like
dude I think I'm gonna have sex with my
girlfriend like do you mind if we used
your back house and he was like yeah
it's like yeah as long as I could smell
the room after me yeah you just smell
your nuts afterwards and then uh so we
went into the back and it was just like
it was just so awkward but like got it
done you're like I didn't even come
I don't know she said it was but I'm not
sure absolutely it was not it might not
have been it might not have been I would
guess now no yeah but we and then our
relationship was just us having sex like
all the time how did you guys break it
off
I forgot what happened I think
she was like she kind of started talking
to another like one of my friends behind
my back or something like that and then
I was like okay like I'm so [__]
cheating yeah you're like some cheating
it was cheating related I just called it
off but there's she also beat the [__]
out of this other girl that I was kind
of like I like oh I was [__] a high
now dude whooped this girl's I feel
really bad about it she whooped this
chick's ass for what because like so she
well it was stupid 14 year old [__] she
was like yeah I don't care if you like
hook up with this other girl like it's
fine that's what she told me at the time
and I was like okay the other girl's
pretty fine so like we hooked up and
then she was mad that like she wasn't
there so she ended up beating the [__]
out of the other girl oh my God and then
like the cops were involved and like I
had to talk I was like getting
interrogated by police at 14 years old
lying to the police I was that made up a
story
just like you're telling this story to
the cop and he looks at you he goes
dick huh
so yeah she was [__] crazy but you
know we just had to do we we're so dumb
like so obviously like when you have sex
with a girl like if you use Lube you're
supposed to use you use blue no well I'm
saying if you do use Lube there's a
specific it's there's specific types
that they use we would we didn't know we
would just use like handled hand lotion
bro this girl had a yeast infection like
none other dude hand lotion like like
just like from Sephora we said what's
the yeast infection no no no no which
girl had the yeast infection
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyways it was a weird experience but I
was 14. can I ask you something yeah
this is completely not racial and you
are Mexican
what does she sound like
exactly what you think
it were her eyebrows yeah they were no
her eyebrows weren't that thin she had
some eyebrows was there this is a
McDonald's
it's just a sticker I just
she definitely wore a lot of eye shadow
she had like the belly butt piercing
belly uh button piercedure belly button
piercing I used to have sex in my room
to Sean Paul Temperature dude
that's just that my parents didn't hear
your parents do [__] they knew they had
[__] again yeah he's [__] the girl
with the crazy eyebrows for the seventh
time dude she was writing me one time
accidentally came inside of her and we
both immediately started crying
oh so like we're she like I was
inexperienced so I just came and thought
that you it was literally uh and then we
both looked at each other and we're like
ah we just started crying because we
thought we had just ruined her life so
we went to writing and you got the
morning after no no it was like we
didn't even get that it was like some
foam chlorine
drink this Clorox [__] it'll be fine
how did you make it out to be this age
now dog this story is insane dude so
when you're 14 and you don't you're too
scared to ask anybody an adult or
somebody that would actually have a coat
hanger we just I Googled I Googled like
what do you do like uh contraceptives or
whatever and there was some kind of foam
there so so one of the things I don't
even know if this exists anymore but you
can like before you have sex there's
like a foam you can put into a girl's
vagina that's supposed to like sterilize
or kill the semen upon the impact yeah I
don't know if this is a real thing
anymore we also got some dispensers from
the mall
no that Rite Aid dude it's Gotta write
it and then so what's the shaving cream
pattern just to let you know it was
whipped cream dude so then we like we
put it in her vagina afterwards and like
pumped it in and we're like all right
like hope you're not pregnant and she
was God she was not pregnant holy you
live life on the edge dude like if I met
up this girl and she came up and
straight up from my space had like the
eyebrows with the [__] lip liner yeah
what are you trying to do later or
whatever you know I'm like we're done
yeah this is not happening I was horny
though
I was horny though I actually had the
[__] belly button picked up and
you're like oh [__] yeah I was 14. I
don't think you ever used a condom
before dude I've used so many columns I
don't like them but I use them I'm also
not used a lot but I I use them I use
them I don't like
so you like want protection or something
because you're like better like gay or
whatever
I don't know I don't care whatever if
you want to do if you're a [__] gay
whatever dude some of those girls like
in like they were so [__] aggressive
so [__] aggressive and mean I
personally only dated one Latina but she
was not like that all right I mean she
was a little hot and spicy but it wasn't
like that though that shit's [__]
crazy they are aggressive like their
version of hitting on you is is calling
you a [__] like they're like oh yeah
what is that like they're like they
bully you they bullied and they're
actually hitting on you but they're like
so what's up you're [__] you're gay
or what dogs like what's going on you're
a [__] I'll [__] you up right now and
like that's she really like wants to go
on a date with you
what the [__] I call them a [__] like
[__] like 12 times
yeah yeah dude I'm telling you man your
[__] past is very precarious I'm
surprised you're not dead yeah yeah
that's crazy yeah it was it was yeah it
was wild for sure and then yeah just I
don't know
then the next girl ended up being like
so I dated another girl after that and
at the time she was really quiet and
like super like Christian she ended up
being a stripper later on in life
she was hot though of course the
Christian stripper girl yeah everybody
liked the the Catholic girl because she
would like on the exterior be very sweet
because she was so repressed she just
wanted hot dogs all day yeah yeah hand
jobs in the library whatever the [__]
not so if you found yourself like a like
a sweet quote-unquote Catholic girl that
wasn't actually very sweet they were the
ones that were down for absolutely
anything so I heard I was hideous in
high school so I never got to experience
yeah yeah but other people tell me
stories yeah so I never got to kind of
true ask me if I use condoms you didn't
use condoms
your idea
their idea they were just like hey you
don't have to know they are they say you
don't have to yeah yeah
did you smash a lot of girls in high
school or let me let's not say that's
actually very crude did you have uh
sexual relations with a lot of women did
you make love to ladies yes a lot well a
lot of men is that count hey now no no I
I had a girlfriend I had girlfriends but
not like I wasn't but you weren't
sleeping around chasing have you ever
like have you ever made love to a woman
like I I mean like yeah you've had sex
with people but like have you ever like
like I'm Gonna Make Love to this lady
have you ever like passionately been
like you know what I mean what do you
mean like sweating fire candles in the
back r b playing
um that's not your wife next and then
there's somebody else have you ever made
love to anybody
how did you have a child
have you made love dude you would be
terrible in court I stepped out of my
mouth
comes out your mouth that you're like
[__] petri dish no I go like this
when did you lose your v card uh when I
was 15.
so much younger than I was ninth grade
summer ninth grade summer yeah I felt
really bad why do you feel bad
um because
we were girlfriend and boyfriend but
then um the way I didn't know how to be
a boyfriend the way okay this is a crazy
thing because I I really liked her Asa
it was a summer camp so then we went to
uh like Universal Studio thing or
whatever the thing wow yeah it was
really nice and then um we we really
liked each other and then for like a
month we had a really nice thing and
then um I think because she was
I feel really bad she was too clingy at
the time to me and then I think I would
just
like a little bit bored of it and then
every day we would do activities and we
were playing basketball this once and
she was sitting on the she was sitting
on the bleacher and uh she was crying
and my friends was like hey
uh why is she crying like and then I was
like oh I don't know and she was on the
bleacher I was like hey stop crying
you are so on the Spectrum it's unreal
oh that is you are straight up on the
Spectrum I know but I felt really bad
and let me tell you something did it
work no
no but I wonder why I want to say this
after because I treated really well
because I want to be but I didn't know
how to do I didn't know how to because I
was so young I didn't know how to see
your girlfriend crying on the bleachers
in a distance and the first thing that
pops into your head is
I know I felt really bad and also I
think I was trying to like impress my
friends
how would that impress your friends I
don't know like I just wanted to be cool
I think like not be like watch me
verbally abuse my [__]
and they were like cool
I felt really bad but I wanted to say
there's like after like five years
uh no I've said like 40 I was like 17 or
whatever I was at my friend's house I
remember and back then we had the
sidekicks
and uh I got it I got and I just
realized this recently like a month ago
but I had the sidekick and I got a text
that says hey I'm a friend of Assad's do
you remember and at the time I was
thinking about finding her to apologize
to her because I was she's a stripper
now because you ruined her life she's a
[__] in Tijuana okay
you're lying it makes a lot of money she
makes a good living stop crying stop
crying get a tattoo on her chest and
stop crying imagine the guy you love
like the person you love like you're
watching them play basketball you're so
supportive you're just watching them
play basketball that's what you're doing
with your day you're a human with
responsibilities you have things you
like things
and you take your time time out of your
day to watch your boyfriend the guy you
love and you start getting emotional and
then his responses from far away too
from like 30 yards away like hey stop
crying no
no
stop crying stop crying stop crying you
didn't know about the decency to get
close to her to tell her
did you even stop crying we're in the
middle of the game
and everything
keep it together
I borrow amplifier
I was playing basketball not even
noticing and then when you yell that
they everyone just turns and goes huh
why is Asa crying I guess she was crying
I felt really really bad so you messaged
her yeah so I couldn't find her on the
thing and I got a text recently but not
recently like at the time 17. I got the
thing and instead it's from her friend
and um and recently my friend I told my
friend this and they're like that's
probably ASA and I was like oh [__]
you're probably right because she didn't
want to yes you didn't want to be the
thing and but a good thing I wrote I was
like oh my God if you have her
information please let me know I I felt
so bad I don't know why I did that
you're just a kid I mean yeah yeah that
was my first girlfriend ever a 100 even
at the age of 15 I would have never done
that are you in ninth grade summer ninth
grade summer not a good summer baby
[Music]
no I just that was again and she's still
on that [__] till this day yeah it's
just like a skeleton waiting for Jason
you helping my second girlfriend was a
Filipino and she taught me I sucked her
titties in in a in a movie theater nice
couple times okay is she taught you I
want people
I want everyone to understand like the
jump that we just went for this guy
making a girl cry and say it was an
accident I really apologize
titties you sucked her titties nice she
taught you how what the she taught me
are you talking she was a freak so she
was you were in the theater and then you
started sucking on her tits and then the
making out there Jason I think you
forgot to do it circles on my TT so
please don't don't do it that way please
please grab under and squeeze a little
harder thank you
little [__] nice she taught you how to
suck and I see how the kids really it
was if it wasn't because of her because
me and also we were like because she's
Japanese and I'm I was pretty
conservative too so we were like it was
kind of uh different because we were
really um like everything was very like
polite but then uh the Filipino was she
was crazy
and she taught me the things she taught
me all the things and making all the
tongue things oh nice so she wasn't
talking about listening
on your booty hole there you go hey now
if you're Filipino and you're out there
right like I've dated uh two Filipino
girls in my whole life yeah right and I
gotta tell you something both those
Filipino girls were hypersexual yeah uh
I don't know what it is and like any any
like pinoys or pinays out there if you
guys can clarify this they're supposed
to use extra wet all right
but they're very uh sexually mature
about the advertisement and a little
aggressive
and their vaginas are extra moist
no but I definitely when I first The
First Filipino girl I ever dated
was the girl that I met at a Halloween
party
and she showed up in a naughty nun
little thing and then it was game over
and let me tell you something it's time
to Boom your moon dude
that's what time it is right now
[__] noon dress so it was my it was
one of my really good friends older
sisters really close friend right so she
was like four years older than me
so we were we were at this Halloween
party and by the way there was already
like red flags I remember this [__] she
was so strong I forgot what was
happening we were drinking at this party
and all of a sudden this girl was just
doing push-ups in the middle of the
party and for some reason I got my dick
hard I was like this is the one for me
I hit her up and then we just started
chatting back and forth but this girl
she I found out that she equated healthy
relationship with having sex multiple
times a day that's what's up no I'm
tired I'm so horny [__] a horny ass
boy
I was
21 at the time right but
I was working like three jobs I was
doing stand-up every [__] night oh
[__] and it's like dog how the [__] am I
gonna [__] that I'm tired yeah I need to
sleep like you have to imagine like
you're in school working uh all day
after that then at night you're trying
to hit these clubs and sometimes I would
have to go all the way to San Francisco
it's a two-hour Drive damn just so I
could do open mics and trying to get my
name out there and then she was just
like I'm tired it's like 3 A.M in the
morning and she's like waiting she was
like she's trying to [__] I'm like I'm
tired and then she just would get
[__] okay she'll call me a [__] whoa
she would call me like a [__]
yo I'm tired like I can't do it all the
time yeah and so it was such a weird
thing and I remember she was still
actually kind of cool because I remember
the first time we hooked up
and I felt like the dick game was good
and then I remember afterwards I was
like
how do you like it she goes it's okay
if it's okay he's really good
it's okay it was really good you're like
where's the bad part of the story well
she said that my [__] I remember my
confidence like [__] chat I was like
what the [__] do you mean it's okay I
was doing mine oh yeah yeah yeah right
but then she started like telling me
like this is what I like this is what I
don't like this is what I feel like you
should do communication but then at that
up my game a lot of course because I was
like oh like not everybody is the same I
found out too later on that she was
telling people that I was gay
wow after I broke up yeah he's gay dude
yeah she kept telling everybody that was
gay damn this girl sounds [__]
awesome dude
[Laughter]
where's the girl dude
I [__] you all the time breaks up yeah
it feels good
she kept telling everybody I was gay and
[__] I'm like I'm like okay
so I broke up with her in the car this
date with this was like the last time I
just couldn't handle this [__] anymore
it wasn't like the sex that made me like
go crazy it was
how she would speak to me because this
[__] would cursed me out all the time I
don't know what the female Joker dude
which is insane I'm telling you she was
[__] nuts and as a young person you
also just equate like this girl wants to
have sex with me all the time you feel
like you're some dope [__] yeah and I
think she knew that about like young men
who like oh how much older she was four
years older than me oh [__] okay yeah so
like I think for her she kind of knew
what's up like oh guys like if I it's
actually a really bad mentality that I
think a lot of um
I think uh girls without a strong sense
of self-have it's like if I suck this
guy's dick or if I [__] him it means
that he'll never leave me which isn't
true you know what I mean they learn
this stuff from like social media or
Tick Tock like this is what men want
because men no no there's like people
who want people to be around because you
have good values we have great
conversations you're there to support me
emotionally and mentally even if you
have a soft dick it's fine yes exactly
even if I can't get it up while I'm
driving like you still love me but for
her she's actually said this to me
verbatim she goes like well if you don't
have sex with me it means you don't love
me and I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about and it was just like too
much for me to handle at you know early
20s I can't handle this dude that's so
it's so crazy like thinking about
because sexuality is such a like you
know at that age teenagers like that's
when it kicks in and it's such like a a
it's it's a deep heavy adult thing but
you have to navigate it as a child as a
child like you don't know and then you
have like you said people that like use
it against you or not against you but
like use it in that way where they're
like I'll just get them to Love Me by
something whatever but like I think in
the future people would like the younger
uh kids would like um have a better
communication about it because I think
recently we just learned about the love
language and I think her love language
you just [__] juice and penis hard yeah
[__] juice penis hard Jesus Christ yeah
your therapist is like this guy doesn't
learn anything in any of